At the heart of polarization, we have a charge attracting opposite charges.
We found something very similar happens when a lightning cloud comes overhead.
These clouds tend to have a lot of negative charge built up at the bottom of them.
We haven't talked about how yet, but this negative charge gets there.
Well, what happens is this negative charge in the clouds causes some of the
negative charges in the ground to be upheld--leaving a deficit of electrons and excess of protons.
This causes the ground to actually become slightly positively charge.
This concept of polarization is essential to the functioning of what we're going to find--
this Benjamin Franklin's solution to saving buildings from lightning strikes.
Let's actually think about what would happen if ??? a perfect sphere,
we change the shape of our conductor, because ??? with a sphere
where the negative charges have a large surface over which they can distribute themselves.
What if we made this a pointier shape, not a sphere but a cone--do I still expect polarization to happen.
But qualitatively, is there any way difference between what happen
with the sphere and what happen with the cone.
At the tip of this cone, is the concentration or density of negative charges higher
than it was with the sphere, lower or the same, and I admit this is quite a tricky question.
Think about it and take your best guess but don't worry if you're wrong.